we want to do the open problem session
you're filming this I guess
if anybody who shows up here and I try
to have to so let me so I wanted to you
know maybe start and then so so I want
to talk about the problem that I've been
thinking about it's a question of
counting the unbroken basis
there is this thing that's probably many
of you don't know what that means I want
to I'm going to tell you what that means
but let me first give you a short
surface study or there will be talks
tomorrow and on Thursday you will see
that there are some recent works that
that now we for any major em you can
count number of basis of M
within 1 plus or minus epsilon factor
time in polynomial of basically the
algorithm uses Markov chains and you'll
see about it
the question here is to basically extend
this to beyond basis of Metroid's so so
let me to motivate this let me first
tell you the chromatic polynomial of a
graph the graph G you can define this
univariate polynomial which counts the
number of colorings of that graph and
it's it's simple to define so let's say
the recursive definition which just says
that yeah if this P is the chromatic
polynomial P of G is equal to this I
mean the chromatic polynomial of G in
terms of that you know variable X is
this minus that and there's a very
simple proof basically like if you want
to color the vertices of G the proper
color first you color first we forget
about there is UV you colored the
remaining graph but now you have to
exclude some colors which colors the
colors that color U and V with the same
color that's exactly the number of
colors in the graph where you contract
the edge UV okay so this exactly gives
you the chromatic polynomial in fact it
proves that it proves that yeah for
every X for every integer X this gives a
number of coloring of G with with with X
many colors follows from this proof that
this is indeed a polynomial so you can
actually you can write it down like this
summation of K
and so the question is what is CKD this
is equal to number of non broken
dependent sets of size K so in
particular if you can solve like I
haven't still said what that is I will
say it but if you can count this we can
we can estimate the coefficients of the
chromatic polynomial minus 1 to the N
it's not okay
yeah okay okay so okay now you can ask
okay who cares about coefficients of
chromatic polynomial so here is one
reason if today is a theorem of stanley
that P of G comma minus 1 so if you
evaluate this polynomial minus 1 this is
equal to number of a cyclic orientation
of the graph
absolute value of this is a cyclic
orientation but the thing is the
coefficients of this has alternating
signs of any evaluated at minus one they
all would have the same sign and if you
can approximate this you can approximate
that quote that number and this is again
another quantity which is open to like
we don't know how to compute there are
there are other applications of this ah
so there's also a generalization of this
so this is just for a graph you can
similarly define a characteristic
polynomial of a mate right there here
okay so we can similarly define what's a
characteristic polynomial of a matrix
and it's the same thing it's summation
of CK minus 1 to the K and again K this
DK is number of number of K independent
sets of tomato as opposed to the graph
so the same thing that that is also
interesting question to it so so there
if you plug in minus 1 you get some you
know interesting quantities if the
matrix pawns to hyperplane arrangements
corresponds the number of regions of the
hyperplane arrangements ok I don't I
don't want to get into it but don't make
it long but yes just just applications
is the application for metro it would be
number of regions
arrangements and number of vertices so
these are like some application now so
let me tell you what is the number of
conveys after all so it's a just a
following you you order the elements of
the matrix
by some arbitrary order so choose an
ordering so let me first define I will
okay
so first let's let's fix an ordering of
the elements let's say 1 is less than 2
less than 3 these are the underlying
elements of your maitre do your graph
whatever then you look at uh-huh then we
say so so fix the cycle so fix okay I
mean it's gonna be a cycle in a graph
but for me so it would be a circuit so
let's let's just think about the graph
case fix a cycle let's say this is a
cycle maybe the edges 2 3 5 & 9 so this
is a cycle in the graph if I if I
exclude 2 so I have this 3 3 elements
this is a broken cycle so if you exclude
the minimum element of a cycle you're
gonna get a broken cycle okay so a
broken cycle
is a cycle where smallest element now a
non broken cycle is any set which is not
like that so for example if I remove
three it's non broke and in general you
can define an unbroken set or an
unbroken independent set it's a it's a
set that has no broken cycle so we say
the I is a non broken independent set if
it has your broken
so so for example maybe that's this is
one this is two this is three four five
then you see that if you want to have a
non broker independent set you
definitely always have to include their
smallest element otherwise it's it's
it's gonna be broken so so let's so I'm
going to definitely have one now okay
for example this is this is now exclude
three or I could exclude too
yeah here this example has only one
cycle so as long as I have the minimum
element of that cycle in my base this is
enough to have an unbroken base but if
you have more cycles it could be it
could get more complicated so that's a
definition of an unbroken base any if
you have an unbroken base any subset of
it would be an unbroken independent set
and that will actually give any number
can independent set is a subset of an
unbroken cycle this is a subset of non
broken base so there's actually a
simplicial complex you can get out of
this there's a whole theory about this
exist there's an interesting theorem or
really inspiring theorem by Whitney that
the number of non broken independent
sets or non broken basis is independent
of this order this is a non-trivial fact
but it is true so for every ordering
that you choose you're going to get the
same number of non broken cycles on an
inside number can independent sets on
our broken basis again for those of you
who know kruskal's algorithm
the output of the crisco's algorithm it
is always an unbroken an unbroken base
I exercise you can proof so there's
always at least one non broken base and
that's our food often crisco's I'll bury
them yeah
and basically the question is to just
count this there is another important
connection here so there is basically
all these results on the counting basis
of matrix connects to these recent
developments on Hodge theory so
basically like there are these recent
works by cream who is here jr. ha and
Eric Katz who show that the coefficients
of this polynomial for animate road is
Lakhan Kane so there's a lot of
interesting linear algebra and geometry
going on but basically like one
inspiring question is can you use that
fact the fact that these coefficients
are law concave to count number of non
broken independent sets or none broken
basis of me
nobody else have
sighs essentially it extends
okay
so what has the classical whole marriage
team say it's rather simple right we
have two finite sets x and y well I mean
there was a version for infinity what I
will not go into this and there is a
relation between them in such a way and
this kind of I mean this supposed to
encode some kind of acceptable partner
such that for every subset a of X the
number of acceptable partner so the the
the the subset of elements Y of such the
subset of Y of elements that are small
acceptable or related to to a and X
satisfies their following inequality all
right so this inequality so and the
statement is then that if such an
inequality holds then well then there
exists small there exists an injective
morphism exist an injective map from X
to Y that is supported on this relation
or in other words there exists a choice
of their you can pair up the elements of
x and y in such a way that X the the
element of that you chose in X is always
related to the element that you chose in
Y alright it's a kind of simple way of
talking about hote theorem ok and so on
on Thursday I think I don't remember
when I will basically say that under
certain conditions this is true for in
algebraic geometry as well and this
essentially takes the form of the
following of object so you have this you
have let's say a commutative graded ring
so let's say a and you want to say that
let's say you have degree 1 in do you
have to agree to here and you want to
construct an injective map from degree
one two degree two and you have a whole
like condition and this whole like
condition says that essentially for all
ideals in a if you look at the dimension
one component alright so I look at the
ideal in degree one and I do look at the
ideal in degree two I have this
dimension in equality okay so this is
kind of the necessary condition for for
there to be an injective map from degree
1 to degree 2 they're supported by the
ring all right otherwise you cannot do
it but is it or was also sufficient and
the answer in general is no for instance
if the ring is non commutative then you
can just take the cross-product okay so
you just think of this a as just r3 and
here it's also r3 and then okay so the
cross products will be expanding in this
sense but it will not in spotting
objective or injective multiplication so
okay so this is maybe because it's non
commutative but you can also construct
commutative examples like that so my
question is I mean in what Cheryl
generality does is hold so on Thursday I
will say that basically for toric
varieties is holds but I really have
barely an understanding on when some of
these expanding properties imply some
objective map okay that's a kind of I
mean I don't know how basic this
question is but it sounds very innocent
but I don't see any any good answer
well I mean okay so you
I mean so the how much is here the Hamid
share in the current structure under its
mother the band minimum of conditions in
construction matching right maybe you
prefer college of MIT a matching and so
I prefer to think of a matching as a map
right for every element on on one side
of your bipartite graph F of a for every
element a on one side F of a is kind of
the next element and so the map is a
particular injective because it's a
matching right it's also subjective and
now you can ask what what happens for
for vector spaces all right so you have
a map between two vector spaces or a
space of maps of between two vector
spaces under which condition do you can
you find an objective map among your
family and now one natural one necessary
condition is is that if you look at all
the subspaces in your starting vector
space and all the possible images then
this some of the target is what that all
the possible images should be at least
as large large in dimension then though
your starting vector space otherwise you
cannot never find an injective map so
now the question is whether this is also
a sufficient criteria and this is turns
out to be wrong all right the cross part
is one example yeah I want to be really
adjective map from my family that's it
here doesn't have to be linear but small
this is restricted to linear map so I
mean this is kind of commutative grated
rings generated in degree one if you
want the similarity was great indeed
theorem right if you have a polynomial
map
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right that's
right
yeah we had a guess for what the
expansion property
well the expansion property that I want
is kind of this ideal this this
expansion property here all right you
you I give you a family of possible maps
right and you want to find an objective
map among them and clearly there
what's the small a necessary condition
is modest monotonicity of dimensions
alright so if you look at you look at
the subspace of your starting vector
space all right then you have to look at
the you look at all the possible images
in alright then this sum of this object
has to be large enough alright this is
just a condition here and our basically
discussed at small something like this
is true and torque varieties but I don't
know how to do this in general
[Music]
okay yeah I could put circle on but
that's kind of yeah yeah you can
construct a finite so kind of find out
version of this and then get back hold
homeric to you for every kind of for
everyone kind of bipartite graph that
satisfies the conditions but I'm really
I mean for me the interesting case is
kind of when you have some kind of
infinite things all right so we yeah
that's I mean they're kind of it's kind
of it's it's a kind of infinite hole
theorem that I'm looking for but with
restricted maps
okay okay I don't think who's next
can I ask a silly class professor
clarification question suppose you just
have to finite dimensional spaces and
then you must have some sort of
relationship right between yeah yeah I
mean this is my family of possible maps
all right and then you want to construct
an objective you know so that what you
get is always in the relationship that
you quickly become false it quickly
becomes false yeah there's a there is a
example by a Karsten it's very nice that
shows that even for polynomials
essentially do you know any other
structure where it works I mean so I
would I will talk about toric varieties
on Thursday and that because John and I
have a few more cases it's always come
from in some way a tuberculoma to a
spherical varieties and there were some
spaces at some some coefficients of
productive groups that Venkatesh
constructed these are kind of I mean
there are kind of I mean but there's a
very special very rigid spaces and
there's always some are very there's
always a different reason that some are
we can prove it but I don't have a
general understanding why this is why
this is to sometimes and why is it what
is for sometimes
yeah okay let me go before there are
more questions
I mean okay I think about what what the
question is
okay so um this is my question this is
basically a conductor of D much like
echo which is related to some of the
things we heard about today but
intriguing so so so let's recall the
central limit theorem for classical
random variables so let's say you have
some let's say you have some some
bounded random variable X which has some
density mu it has a density with respect
to a big measure then okay then then we
know something like if you take iid
copies of X and you scale them so that
oh yeah let's suppose the variance let's
say the mean is 0 the variance is 1 then
we know that if you take a sum of
independent copies and scale by the
scales of the variance remains fixed
this converges to but there's actually a
more quantitative version of this fact
that's something about the entropy of
these variables so we know that so let's
so let's define the entropy of a measure
in the usual way so if it has a density
it's just alright so
that's the entropy so so so one thing
which is actually true in the central
limit theorem is that as you look at
these sums and you let n go to infinity
the entropy increases so this so every
stem proved in the 50s that if you take
so so let's say you take two independent
copies of this random variable that
corresponds to convolving this latter
with itself and I'm going to use this
notation to mean you just rescale by
square to make the various fixed so then
he proved that the entropy of this
called this is greater than the entropy
of just mu proving that this is actually
monitor and n was open for over 50 years
and there is a paper of artstein ball
varta and nor mo for which actually
proves that if you look at the entropy
of these sums this is monotone so as n
gets bigger this entropy actually
increases what I want to talk about is
is a ok so so maybe before that I should
mention there's an analogue of this in
in free probability which we heard a
little bit about today so there's an
operation called the free convolution
okay so takes two measures and spits out
another measure
I won't redefine what it is it's a
different notion of Independence there's
a there's a quantity called free entropy
a scoop which the appropriate definition
is it's a double integral of log and
this looks kind of weird it doesn't look
like it's so related to this but this is
actually a log of a volume of something
so it has a lot of the properties that
entropy has and there's a result of so
tanked 0:05 which proves that if you now
play the same game but with the free
convolution it's still true so you look
at the free convolution of compactly
supported measure and you look at the
free entropy this is also monotone
increasing in n and in this case you
know the appropriate limiting
distribution is a semi-circle log which
maximizes the free entropy subjective
variance so it's like pentose conjecture
is that the same thing is true for
finite free convolution which is what we
saw some talk about
so so so that's classical this is free
so what's finite free convolution so if
you have two polynomials let's say there
are characteristic polynomials of some
matrices so this is a characteristic
polynomial Daigo matrix a this is the
characteristic so matrix B then you can
define the finite free convolution so
let's say these are n by n matrices and
you can find free convolution as the
expected characteristic polynomial of a
plus Q P Q transpose where Q is random
orthogonal matrix and we know that this
has real roots so what this does this
gives you an operation which takes two
discrete measures on endpoints that's
what a polynomial of degree n is and
spits out another and now you can you
can mimic this and define a notion of
entropy for a polynomial so what's the
definition what's called AIT's of n of a
polynomial well this is a double
integral and just gonna take it to be a
double sum so it's a summation over
pairs of roots IJ log lambda I minus 1
and there's a normalization factor of 1
over N
so so so four four polynomial B which
has it's like a discretization of this
it's actually a natural quantity from
algebraic point of view it's just up to
this normalization factor
it's just log of the discriminant so
just like bancos conjecture is that this
quantity is monotone with respect to the
finite freaking gooz so the baby case is
a bit forget forget about the end thing
which was relatively hard to show even
in the classical case let's say you take
two polynomials and take the finance
free convolution well that's going to
increase the variance of the root so you
have to rescale everything to make the
variance small and the right thing to do
is to divide the roots by square root
two again and the conjecture is this is
this is increase and I mean we check
this experimentally it's it's true
we've not approved several special cases
of it but there's no I mean I'm time
quite sure this is true but the the
problem I mean you know and all these
proofs if you look at all these proofs
you you have to somewhere use the fact
that these random varies from random
variables in some sense and the random
variables can have things such as a
Joint Distribution here this is a very
elementary statement about discriminant
essentially a polynomial but there we
don't know how to define random
variables we just have you discrete
matter
so this phenomenon is probably some
shadow of some interesting thing that's
happening but we don't know I think
we're just lacking the definitions to
prove but if you can I think you'll find
something you'll find some interesting
news I should mention that this is so I
mean there's a version of this for two
different polynomials but if you only
care about real rootedness this is
actually saying something interesting
about
the discriminant is a measure of how
real root of the polynomial is so recall
that the boundary of the set of real
rooted polynomials is polynomials a
double root which I discover nonzero so
what this is saying is when you do this
convolution operation you make the power
on your more real good and yeah so that
it's also interesting for that part
anyways conjectures do yeah it sorts
articulating the fact that the roots
repel that if you have some polynomial
that already has some discover and when
you apply so Jonathan mentioned that
okay there's a version of this for two
different polynomials and Jonathan
mentioned that all linear all linear
transformations preserving degree and
rootedness can be written like this so
what this would be saying is that if you
apply a linear operator that preserves
real rootedness for degree and
polynomials the roots repel some
concrete things related to this cover so
we saw there sub modularity and equality
or convolutions correct see what the
Destroyers actually do this operation so
that's a good question so there's some
modular inequality is a statement about
the largest I mean okay it's not true
it's the statement about the Cauchy
transforms the roots but it's I mean the
way it's used is usually just to reason
about the extreme root it's not very
sensitive about the spacings of the
roots on the inside you don't expect the
Cauchy transform to care about the
delicate details of spacing
roots on the inside this conjecture is
some statement about the global facing
of that's right but this doesn't put pay
special attention to the extreme boots
it cares this is not what happens in the
interior where as the Cauchy transform
is really something that's concerned
with I mean puts a lot more weight on
the extreme root is there anything now
what about whether the spirit
under this convolution yeah I mean for
specific cases things are known this is
this most of it is not published so I
don't mean I I know several people who
have results about this I don't know
like them but but but nothing nothing in
general
yeah is it no one if you just get rid of
the root - oh yeah itz if you get rid of
a group yeah so your question is if you
were places with unit area to detain
anything it does not the polynomials are
literally the same so you can do
orthogonal unitary or even sign
permutations here different from the
yep we'll be there meet ya
okay so we know how to prove this one
okay there's a version of this or two
polynomials we know how to prove it one
of the program is a hermit power that's
one of the special cases that's yeah
something we worked out with Bhima and
Adam that corresponds to proving this in
the case of one of the you can ask this
question what if one of these things is
Gaussian that's relatively easier to
prove so we can prove that
if you have complex period power Romeo's
I have no idea so yeah I guess
everything written here makes sense for
complex rooted polynomials it might
any
yeah have to do with this conference on
that fastest question before money
[Music]
okay so let's say you take a random word
uniformly at random
we're like the symbols and the words are
the numbers between 1 and n it has
length D a random string and then let L
is of W you know the length of the
longest increasing subsequence in W
increasing means non decreasing and
interested in the expected value of L is
W we first say a lower bound whatever
you have a string you can get a non
increasing or non decreasing subsequence
or an increasing something units by just
taking all the copies of one or you can
take all the copies of two or you can
take all the copies of three etc and one
of these will have length at least D
over and the longest increasing
subsequence the over N so the
expectation will be at least this so it
turns out this is something I proved
with John right we were studying a
problem in like quantum learning we
proved this it's not too much bigger
it's not much it's bigger by at most two
times square root D so let me just now
you might say what's the open problem
because that's the answer I'll just say
a couple things to entreat you first of
all the open problem is to prove this
without using representation theory
which was how we proved it and just let
me about a comment this too is like the
two is comes from like the edge of the
Wigner semi circle distribution that's
why it came to my mind for this
conference deva katta entertaining to
prove this when capital n is to about I
know how to do with combinatorics that's
a random binary string
okay that's the whole question are there
any questions
yes why would you like to prove you know
wouldn't you what something else yeah
you could feel like you know why it's
true if you're a person like me as
opposed to like be able to sum follow
with some calculation that maybe your
co-author worked out
is there another open question
it
I guess that's it